always a very special day around major
league baseball jackie robinson day as
we get set for the a's and the tigers
the first of a four-game series here at
the coliseum and
sean manaya is ready to go sean manaya
both these pitchers bipster looking for
their first respective wins of 2021 now
here's what we know about mania two
starts
both against the astros that's a tough
assignment his last timeout did not get
the decision but the a's won and he
deserved a w check those spikes out
right there exactly number 42 yeah so
and he's got the jacket robinson on the
on the stirrups grossman swinging a miss
and that's how our ball game starts a
mania strikeout this is the first time
wilson ramos catches
this year he did catch him in spring
training and struggled a little bit with
some of his stuff
yeah and one of the reasons is uh aj
knows that turek throws a lot of
breaking balls in that split finger in
the dirt and swinging a pop-up
shallow center field racing out to make
the catch one two three first inning for
skubal chavon leads out for the a's no
score bottom of the second against tarik
skubal the left-hander and he hits a
high-fly ball right center jones back in
the alley at the track he's right to the
wall leaping at the wall and he makes a
great catch
so here's olson back in the lineup
tonight
this one's hit high in here to center
field jacoby jones going back
[Applause]
[Music]
america park is
big right center to left center biscotti
anderson kemp bottom three is the a's
looking for their first hit against
school
that one is ripped to left field
and that baby's golf
clears the out of town scoreboard and
it's one nothing oakland biscotti
continues to make loud contact
and the home run ball bites squibble yet
again
phase one tigers nothing
and got this pitch and man did he smoke
it see that's what you don't have to
worry about the wind when you hit it
like that that's called a line drive
and that will
that will do well against any wind
blowing that's like
carpio and dallas's drive when the
wind's blowing in your face you you know
hit it downwind now bases are loaded
another big pitch the 3-2 swinging a
missile catamount strikes riding high
fastball
so he strikes out the side but it took a
while to get there fourth strikeout ends
the third candelario with a single in
the fourth and there's two outs here's
willy castro slice to right field a lot
of room down there
and that is a fair ball
jam into the corner markana kind of gave
up on it and candelario will score
he was off on the swing and willie
castro has himself
an rbi double
bob melvin's coming out
i suppose they want to see to make sure
that it landed in fair territory
[Applause]
see the chalk yeah maybe it was the wind
because it's flowing out to left field
so
swirling wind kept that fair
yeah the
correct call made in new york ted
barrett indicates so
but really castro needed that yes he did
and now here's elvis trying to break the
1-1 tie the a's don't want to squander
this opportunity swung on fly ball right
center field that should break the tie
badu coming in actually he's coming in
shallow make the catch here comes olson
here comes the throw it's not even close
and
olson will waltz across the plate
standing up a sac fly for elvis it's a
2-1 oakland lead as andrews gets his
third rbi of the year that is great
third base coaching by kante and a
little bit of the scouting report for
the a's because that was not a deep fly
ball at all like you said
i'm not sure you're gonna run on most
right fielders in that situation here's
the pitch to jacoby jones and he swings
and pops it up then the first baseline a
short right field olson going out over
the shoulder and he corrals it with a
great catch and made it look easy the
long and loping strides of matt olson
going down the line in fair territory
over the shoulder cradles that ball
and quickly two away and that'll bring
up robbie grossman that was a swing and
they missed that is a good inning for
sean a couple strikeouts here it's the
bottom of the fifth and the a's have a
2-1 lead the delivery now to matt is
swinging on driven deep to right center
field jones going back in the alley he
will turn and watch it fly
and matt olson has hit it out
that's the second long ball tonight
and the a's take a 3-1 lead
up into the seats in right center field
above the 388 mark
a big-time blast right there
pierced right through the marine layer
[Applause]
and he knew when he made contact that
these conditions tonight as
pitcher friendly as they are we're not
going to contain that swing
that's his second home run of the year
he is really picking up the long ball
pace tigers have not put much pressure
on mania at all three singles and then a
willy castro double for their one run
nico goodwin betting against sean manaya
turns on one and sends one to deep
center field way back and that ball's
out of here
nico goodram a solo bomb to bring
detroit to where they want
nikko good room from the right side
number one
and the tigers cut the oakland lead to
three to two how about that swing looks
like a fastball up in the zone
put a severe buggy whip on that baby
you know the ball doesn't travel at
night time so loriana will step in with
andrew set third canna at second lowry
at first and alex lang is the new
pitcher that's outside and the eights
take a 4-2 lead wow four walks in the
inning ramone gets his fifth rbi the
easy way
plating andrews
canada goes to third lowry to second and
if you're aj hinch vince i guess you
knew what you signed up for yep growing
pains with a young pitching staff so now
it's 42 and here's matt the set base is
loaded and the fish to chaplin ready
it's on the way and matt it's a rocket
to left center field good room back in
the alley and it's over his head and off
the wall one run is scored and here's
lowry around third they're going to
score him and going all the way to third
is loriano on a blistering two base hit
to left center by chapman and the ears
get the big hit they've been looking for
and they take a six to two lead here's a
3-1 pitch and that's taken inside for
ball four and the a's take a 7-2 lead so
here's lowry he's one for three walked
and scored his last time up he's looking
to build on their 7-2 lead line to left
to base it and the rbi string continues
for lowry he's made it six games in a
row picks up his 12th of the year
end of score is tony kemp and the a's
lead it now eight to two
willie castro bounces one for three with
a double from the right side
this one down into the right field
corner by willy castro
nunez will score
and lily castro
will dig all the way to third and get
there with a head first slide
an rbi triple for willy castro that
brings up jonathan scope swing the line
drive to left field hit it too hard tony
kemp had to jump up and make the catch
willie castro will tag and trot home
they're one out away from winning
their fifth straight game swan
a high fly ball short center mariana
coming on he's right there he makes the
catch the ball game is over and that's
five straight wins for the oakland a's